Up to now, what we've talked about is
how to reduce the latency for requiring the lock
and the contention when the lock is released.
So far we've not talked about fairness. What do
we mean by fairness? Well, if multiple people
are waiting for the lock, should we not be
giving the lock to the guy that made the
lock request or tried to acquire the lock first.
Unfortunately, in Spinlock, there is no way to distinguish
who came first. Because, as soon as the lock
is released, they are going to try and gab the
lock. And, it's entirely up for grabs, as to,
who may be the winner. So next, we're going to
do is, we going to look at a way by
which we can, we can ensure fairness in the
lockout position. Now many shops and restaurants, busy ones,
that is, often use a ticketing system to
ensure fairness for those who are waiting to get
served. So for instance, in this example here
let's say, I walk in the deli shop. And
my ticket is 25, and I notice that currently they're serving 16. So I know that
I have to wait for a little bit of time. And you know, once my number comes up,
I can get served. So this is actually, and if I know that there at least nine
people ahead of me who need to be served before my turn comes up. And by similar
argument. If people come after me, I know
that they're not going to served before me. That's the
basic idea that we're going to use in this ticket
lock algorithm. The ticket lock algorithm is basically implementing
what I described to you as to what happens in
a deli shop. The lock data structure has two fields to
it, a next-ticket field, and a now-serving field. And the
lock algorithm, in order to acquire a lock, what I'm going to
do is I'm going to mark my position. And the way
I do that is I'm going to get a ticket just like
when I walk in a deli shop. I get a unique
ticket, I get a unique ticket by doing a fetch and
increment on the next ticket field of the log data structure,
and when I do the structure increment, I get a unique number and this number is
also advanced, exactly like how it would happen in a deli shop. And once I have
my position marked, as to when I can get my
lock. I can then wait by procrastination.
And what I'm doing here is pausing to see if I've won my. Lock by an
amount that is proportionate to the difference between my ticket value and who
is being served currently. And after there's amount of dealing, I'm going to go
and check if the now serving value equals my ticket value. And if, if it is,
then I'm done, I can return. Otherwise I
go back to looping. So basically I'm looping, waiting
for, waiting for my number to be up so that I can assume that I've got the
lock. And how am I going to get, get
this information that, that my ticket is up for
serving? That is going to be done with the current
holder of the lock. He's going to come and release
the lock, and when he releases the
lock, he's going to increment the now_serving value in
the lock data structure, and that's all,
eventually, the now_serving will advance to be equal
to my_ticket, and I'll get the ticket, and then I can, I can return from
the acquire lock. Now this algorithm is good,
that it preserves fairness, but you notice that,
everytime the lock is released, there is now
serving value that is in my local cache is
going to be updated with a cache coherence
mechanism, and that's going to cause contention on the
network so On the one hand frener is achieved and on the other hand, we have not
really completely gotten rid of the contention that can
happen on the network when the lock is released.